- (Mark) So Wendy,
- (Wendy) Yes?
(Wendy yawns, Wendy and Mark laugh)
- (Mark) Where are you from originally?
- North Carolina, Charlotte.
- (Mark) And how long
have you been out here?
- (Wendy) 17 and a half years.
- (Mark) 17 and a half years.
And what, what got you out here?
- My ex-husband, he beat me up.
Well, I had a six week old baby that died.
- (Mark) You had a six week
old baby that died? Of what?
- (Wendy) Her lungs gave out.
- (Mark) Six weeks?
- (Wendy) Six weeks.
- (Mark) Was that your only child?
- (Wendy) Oh, my first
child, my last child.
And two weeks after I buried
her, I caught my best friend
and my husband in our bed making love.
Yeah, and I lost my mind.
You know, I just buried my baby, our baby.
And this is how you repay me?
I pictured the life of our child.
Don't spare him a thought,
he isn't worth it.
So he shook this knife on
me, he wanted to cut me.
- (Mark) Your husband?
- (Wendy) Yeah. So this
fucking, ain't nobody will.
I smiled and said, "get
out, you and her and both
out my face" going was this,
just get out, leave me alone.
And he's a stalker.
He likes to stalk.
So a friend of mine told me
California is a nice place to start over.
So the battered women's
shelters down there got in touch
with me, got place down here and
they bought me a bus
ticket to come down here.
Well, I get here and I lose
my luggage. Everything.
Everything my son had, and everything.
And like two months I called
the police department.
They'll take you down
there, I'll call the police.
I called the police and
this is where they bring me.
Down to skid row.
- (Mark) And you've been here ever since.
Tell me about your childhood.
You grew up, with one parent?
- (Wendy) My grandmother raised me.
- (Mark) Your grandmother?
- (Wendy) When she died.
I was eight.
She died when I was eight.
My father came back into the
picture and he was abusive.
My grandmother passed away.
My father beat me,
for a whole month telling me
I killed her, it was my fault.
It was my fault, my fault.
So that's like eight year old.
So, so I believing stuff like that.
My grandma was my world.
She was my only thing I had
this whole world taking care
of me, protected me, loved me and
it killed me when she died.
God, I love her.
She had cancer.
That's why I have it.
- (Mark) You have, what kind of cancer?
- (Wendy) I have stomach cancer.
That's what I'm dying of.
That's why I only have six months left.
- (Mark) You also have AIDS?
- (Wendy) HIV? Yeah.
- (Mark) What drugs are you doing?
- (Wendy) Crack.
- (Mark) You been doing
crack the whole time?
- (Wendy) Yeah. Oh,
that's all that appears.
I don't stick no needles and none of that.
I came to the hospital.
- (Mark) You have family?
- (Wendy) None.
- (Mark) So just you?
- (Wendy) Just me.
- (Mark) So after your
grandmother passed away,
you stayed with your..?
- (Wendy) Father.
And he was abusive.
He raped me, it was so... I
don't want to talk about it.
It was so terrible.
He used to take belt buckles
and beat me in the face
with them.
All these scars, they're from my father.
Well, some of them are from here but,
he slammed me and shot
me in the ass with a gun,
just to see if it felt good.
- (Mark) He shot you?
- (Wendy) I'd show you the Mark.
It's like a mole, at the back of my ass.
And he didn't ask me how that
feel, my father was sick.
- (Mark) Your mom?
- (Wendy) My mom, I met her at one time.
- (Mark) And why was your
mom not with you as a child?
- (Wendy) 'Cause she didn't want me
- (Mark) Was she an addict?
- (Wendy) I don't know
Mark, nobody ever explained
to me that part.
All I know is she didn't want no baby.
But I have three half
brothers that she had.
- (Mark) But do you, I mean, your
your view of the world must be affected
by what you've been through
or still going through.
How do you view the world,
is it a horrible place?
Or do you see hope or?
- (Wendy) I, I see hope now,
even though I have six months
left, least I'm inside now.
I got a little kitten on the way.
I can't wait, gonna name her Penny.
Little girl.
She about like this, no, I'll
need real hunting for this
but I got it right there.
- (Mark) What do you do for money?
- (Wendy) I get care.
I get that nine days per sec
or eight, eight days or so.
- (Mark) Great, Wendy thank
you for talking to me.
- (Wendy) Thank you, Mark.